his assistant attorney general under
President Reagan I prepared a report for
the Attorney General entitled the
Constitution in the year 2000 choices
ahead this report sought to identify a
range of areas in which significant
constitutional controversy could be
expected soon twenty years by preparing
this report I sought to provide a
glimpse of the stakes involved in the
then ongoing public debates over federal
judicial selection in competing
understandings of the proper role of the
judiciary and they also sought to
identify what I call Forks in the road
with the camera to change the counselors
American constitutionalism the
controversy is identifying the
Constitution year 2000 as important as I
think they were haulin significance
before the controversies that I think
will almost certainly rise over the next
several decades for those of us I assume
there's at least a few available in a
traditional constitutionalism to James
Madison's Constitution the resolution of
these emerging controversies will
determine whether the Constitution of
2030 bears any resemblance to the
constitution of the Reagan years much
less to the Constitution that guided
this nation for most of its first two
centuries it is critical that those who
are committed to preserving our
traditional Constitution understand
clearly the nature of the upcoming
litigate of offensive by proponents of
like all the 21st century Constitution
there is nothing that such components
would like more than to transform beyond
recognition and with a minimum of nelson
public attention Constitution that
served this country during the
eighteenth nineteenth and twentieth
centuries to render the United States
the freest the most prosperous and the
most creative nation is you the world if
there's an overarching theme
what proponents of the 21st century
Constitution wish to achieve is the
mention of the democratic and
representative processes of American
government it is the replacement of a
system of Republican self-government
with a system of judicial government in
which substantive policy outcomes are
increasingly determined by unaccountable
federal judges rather than merely
defining broad rules of the game for the
legislative and executive branches of
government the new constitution would
compel specific outcomes yes there would
remain the forms of the founders
constitution the bicameral legislature
the periodic elections the states but
the most important decisions those
determining the nature and direction of
the continuing American experiment and
liberty and self-rule would increasingly
be undertaken by courts especially by
federal courts populated by lawyers and
black robes lawyers serving lifetime
tenures and lawyers unencumbered by the
messiness of having to persuade
constituencies or the representatives of
other constituencies of the wisdom of
their ideas concerning the role of
government these courts would be
unmoored in any serious way from the
language that we the people had placed
in their constitution and informed
instead by the perspectives of a legal
profession whose self interests are ever
more distinct from the productive sector
and by international elite opinion and
by creative and innovative legal
academics it will be I submit the
California referendum process written
national a process by which the
decisions of millions of voters on
matters such as racial quotas social
services funding and immigration policy
have been routinely overturned by a
single judge acting in the name of the
Constitution a constitution that not
only would have been unrecognizable to
its creators but unrecognizable to all
the past generations of judges who have
ever sat on the courts of this land